[Música]
la organización no gubernamental
transparencia internacional publicó su
informe anual sobre la corrupción en el
mundo América Latina es la región peor
parada con Venezuela Haití Nicaragua en
el fondo de la lista regional
El Congreso de Perú aplaza por tercera
vez el debate y la votación del proyecto
de ley que busca un posible adelanto
electoral para este 2023 un pedido que
resuena desde hace semanas en las calles
del país durante el levantamiento social
la nueva fecha para el debate es para
este miércoles a las 11 de la mañana
la ciudad de tulcán en Ecuador se llevó
a cabo un nuevo encuentro del gabinete
binacional Ecuador Colombia en el que se
reunieron por primera vez dos
presidentes Guillermo lasso y Gustavo
Petro los mandatarios llegaron a
compromisos En temas que incluyen medio
ambiente seguridad e integración
ampliamos desde quito
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos con el informe
anual elaborado por transparencia
internacional que apuntó que América
Latina es la región más afectada por la
corrupción con países con puntuaciones
muy bajas como Venezuela Haití Nicaragua
en contrapartida Uruguay es la única
nación latinoamericana entre los 20
menos corruptos del mundo Ramiro cué
Barberena nos cuenta más
América Latina la región más afectada
por la corrupción así lo afirmó el
índice de percepción de la corrupción el
informe anual que elabora la ong
transparencia internacional que fue
publicado el martes y que colocó a
varios países de latinoamérica con
puntuaciones muy bajas en este rubro
sobresalen Venezuela Haití Nicaragua
Honduras y Guatemala bueno tenemos la
verdad Donde efectivamente no hay
capacidad alguna es de lucha contra la
corrupción en el caso de Venezuela
podemos hablar incluso de una
cleptocracia pero yo diría que además lo
que nos preocupa es que estos países que
tienen un claro déficit democrático y de
lucha contra la corrupción eh No son la
excepción en la región y se le están
sumando noticias preocupantes en otros
países cercanos como puede ser Guatemala
Honduras El Salvador y donde También
tenemos que tener la alerta puesta según
transparencia internacional una
organización que financiada por dinero
de distintos estados a nivel global la
corrupción no ha sido combatida como
correspondía y transformó el mundo en un
lugar más peligroso la desconfianza
pública incrementó e incluso derivó en
episodios de violencia como lo sucedido
en Brasil a inicios de 2023
bueno claramente necesitamos fortalecer
mucho más las instituciones nosotros
creemos que por ejemplo algo que
preocupa mucho en América Latina es la
debilidad y la falta de independencia de
los sistemas de Justicia esto obviamente
presienta la impunidad y también produce
que hay un terreno fértil para el
crecimiento del crimen organizado y
mayor violencia y seguridad eso es algo
que caracteriza a la región el país
latino con mayor imagen positiva es
Uruguay elogiada por una democracia
Clara e instituciones sólidas la
recomendación de transparencia
internacional apunta por ese camino
reforzar entidades públicas cooperar
para erradicar la corrupción y dar
mejores condiciones de vida a sus
ciudadanos
empervo el congreso volvió a aplazar por
tercera vez el debate y la votación de
un posible adelanto de las elecciones
para el 2023 así las cosas se espera que
el legislativo peruano debate al tema
este miércoles alrededor de las 11 de la
mañana entre tanto nuevamente miles de
ciudadanos Se tomaron las calles de Lima
la capital para seguir mostrando su
rechazo al gobierno de la presidenta
dinavoluarte a quien piden que renuncie
a su cargo estamos decididos a seguir
hasta las últimas consecuencias a fin de
que la democracia en nuestro país se
restablezca y podamos vivir en
desarrollo en paz Hablamos ahora de la
reunión presidencial que tuvo lugar
entre los presidentes de Colombia
Gustavo Petro y de Ecuador Guillermo
lasso en la ciudad fronteriza de tulcán
en Ecuador los mandatarios y sus
respectivos equipos adoptaron 79 nuevos
compromisos para este año en siete ejes
que incluyen medio ambiente seguridad e
integración nuestro corresponsal en
Quito Gustavo Ortega nos amplía
fue el décimo primer encuentro bilateral
entre Colombia y Ecuador que tuvo siete
ejes prioritarios seguridad defensa
infraestructura conectividad ambiente
economía cultura e integración
fronteriza una reunión bilateral donde
Gustavo Petro exhortó a su padre
ecuatoriano Guillermo lasso incrementar
la unidad de ambas naciones a través del
océano Pacífico desarrollar una política
más agresiva de incautación de drogas
preservar la selva amazónica y el
cuidado del medio ambiente y que
Colombia Ecuador se conviertan en la
puerta de conexión del continente
sudamericano con la ampliación terrestre
de la carretera Panamericana Gustavo
Petro también anunció que la carretera
fronteriza entre Ecuador popayán y Cali
será el principal vínculo de ambos
países con la región que contará con una
fuerte inversión monetaria luego de una
reunión privada entre ambos mandatarios
se afirmó la declaración presidencial
entre Colombia y Ecuador Guillermo lasso
resaltó que las siete áreas de
desarrollo bilateral manejan
coincidencias con el vecino país en el
área ambiental implementando un consejo
binacional delitosa ambientales De igual
forma un común apoyo para preservar los
bosques amazónicos ambos países
activarán trabajos más locales
relacionados al decomiso de vehículos
entre ambas naciones De igual forma
Ecuador resaltó la decisión de ambos
gobiernos de eliminarlas tras
burocráticas para la ampliación
comercial y un plan de seguridad y
defensa para la lucha contra el crimen y
el narcotráfico entre ambas naciones
finalmente además adelantó que ambos
países podrán convertirse en proveedor
de energía eléctrica hacia Norteamérica
un evento que tuvo lugar en la ciudad
ecuatoriana de tulcán centrado en las
coincidencias a pesar de las diferencias
políticas
en la academia Nacional de policía de
Puerto Príncipe la capital de Haití tuvo
lugar Este martes al funeral de tres
uniformados asesinados por bandas
armadas los hechos tuvieron lugar a
inicios de mes cuando los policías se
encontraban de servicio en medio de la
ola de violencia que desangra al país
caribeño el pasado jueves oficiales de
policía bloquearon las calles y entraron
por la fuerza al Principal aeropuerto
del país para protestar por los
recientes asesinatos
como más difícil la institución policial
no está fallando en su misión estamos
pasando por un momento difícil
la institución policial está devastada
pero de inmediato nos levantaremos
nuevamente para continuar con nuestras
responsabilidades de proteger y servir
al pueblo
este miércoles tendrá lugar en
Washington la primera reunión entre Joe
biden y el presidente de la cámara de
representantes del republicano Kevin
mccarthy después de que este asumiera al
Cargo en ella hablarán del aumento del
límite del endeudamiento del país medida
que pide el presidente para que el país
no entren de falta a partir de junio
anteriormente nuestro corresponsal en
Washington Cristóbal Vázquez nos contaba
Cómo se llega a esta reunión Y si están
muy alejadas las posturas de
republicanos y demócratas al respecto de
la deuda
están bastante alejadas las posturas las
posturas del partido republicano es de
más recorte en programas sociales para
poder como dicen ellos pues no seguir
con este este chorro libre de gastos que
tienen este momento la administración de
Joe biden concretamente los republicanos
y Kevin mccarthy lo que están buscando
es recortes en programas sociales como
Medicare y como el Social Security que
son los programas que de alguna forma le
brindan a los adultos mayores seguridad
en salud y seguridad en pensión y pues
están pidiendo precisamente recortes en
estos programas para
así poder empezar a negociar el límite
de la deuda lo que argumentan los
republicanos es que se necesita tener un
control más
exhausto de los gastos del gobierno para
que los republicanos pues aprueben
aumentar la deuda sin embargo la postura
de la Casa Blanca es estos programas que
son básicamente algunos de los pocos
programas que tiene el gobierno de
Estados Unidos en temas de bienestar
social y en temas de salud para los
adultos mayores y pues lo que están
diciendo varios medios nacionales es que
concretamente el presidente biden le va
a pedir a Kevin mccarthy mañana que se
comprometa en dos puntos primero en
decir públicamente que no va a permitir
que Estados Unidos entre segundo que
presente una propuesta presupuestal para
precisamente evitar que se tenga que
subir el límite de la deuda para
financiar proyectos básicos y proyectos
fundamentales como la seguridad social
en este país
cerramos en Buenos Aires la capital
Argentina donde se inauguró una
exposición sobre el artista mexicana
Frida Kahlo se trata de una exposición
inmersiva que acerca al público la vida
y obra de una de las pintoras más
ilustres de la región a través de
proyecciones que dan vida a sus obras
marcadas por el dolor físico constante
que sufría desde niña tras haber sufrido
un accidente de tranvía y la polio la
exposición se podrá visitar en Buenos
Aires hasta marzo
con estas imágenes cerramos este
informativo sigan conectados a France 24
[Música]